ici nous avons les lignes n et u
constatons que les trains qui sont au
vert sont à l'heure ici nous avons deux
trains qui sont légèrement en retard ce
sont des trains vides qui s'achemine
tranquillement vers leurs pères leurs
dépôts c'est ici derrière plus ces
écrans que l'information prend forme et
transit jusqu aux voyageurs
nous sommes au poste de coordination de
l'information du réseau transilien
chargé de transmettre les messages
voyageurs sur les différentes
plateformes numériques nous
l'information elle vient du cot le code
c'est le centre opérationnel transilien
en fonction de la gravité de l'incident
et en fonction des prescriptions qui
nous sont données on va diffuser ou non
l'information sur sur les médias distant
application transilien site internet ou
transilien moby les médias les voilà
retard accident suppressions de trains
seront envoyées sur ces réseaux
permettant la notification de
l'information aux clients l'impact du de
l'incident doit être suffisamment
significatif pour que le client
change sa stratégie de déplacement pour
ça que quand on diffuse une information
il faut que l'allongement de temps de
parcours subie par le client soit
supérieure à 10 minutes en dessous de 10
minutes
l'information est relayée en gare via
les écrans info gare et via les annonces
sonores
les notifications sont aussi relayés sur
le fil twitter du réseau qui compte
soixante mille abonnés ici quatre
personnes travaillent en tant que
permanent pour le relais d'environ 300
incidents par mois en février seulement
douze incidents ont été relevés sur la
ligne rennes et deux sur la ligne e u
des chiffres très faible comparé à
l'ensemble du réseau
le pc info s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un
travail contractuel avec le stif avec
pour objectif de produire une meilleure
information dans le cadre d'un trafic
perturbé